6 31 am
tuesday the 8th of december 2020
history is made
margaret keenan a 90 year old
grandmother from coventry
[Applause]
becomes the first patient in the world
to receive the pfizer biontech
covid19 vaccine i thought it was a joke
to tell you the truth to start with
i couldn't believe it you know but i'm
happy it's happened
and now i've done it and hopefully
it'll help other people come along and
do as i did and as you've been watching
the pandemic and you've seen the effect
how did that make you feel oh
terrible of what it's done to people you
know
i this is a terrible total disease so we
do we do want rid of it you know so
anything that helps it's a bonus isn't
it
never has the uk undertaken mass
immunization
on this scale it's the day that may
parsons
the nurse who administered margaret's
vaccine has been praying for
i've never seen so much death in such a
short period of time and
this is such a positive step towards
stopping that and i think
all of my medical colleagues my nursing
colleagues everyone in the trust
just wants all of this to kind of stop
second in line for the vaccine in
coventry was inpatient william
shakespeare a famous name for an
historic moment
groundbreaking i think yeah
um it could
make a difference to our lives from now
on couldn't it
dillis and patrick have faced much
together in their 65 years of marriage
they had a surprise this morning we've
been to another clinic and they asked
when they my age and she said are you
interested
in having the test covered i think yeah
you love it
how difficult has the pandemic been
fingering
very grim it's the it's the we like out
because
obviously we're retired we like our
holidays
frequent should have been cancelled
in london boris johnson returned to the
hospital trust
that saved his life when he contracted
coronavirus
how's that it's all for britain it's all
for britain that's right after speaking
to some of the first patients attending
guys hospital
the prime minister tempered his
excitement with this warning
it will gradually make a huge huge
difference
but i stress gradually because you know
we're not
there yet we haven't defeated this virus
yet and it's
very important for people to understand
not far from the prime minister in
croydon
george dyer waited patiently for his
turn
i miss people i'm quite happy to go to a
big shopping center and sort of rub
shoulders with people you know
i miss the crowd but the point is
when it started i thought well they want
you to stay indoors so that's what i'll
do
across the border in wales craig atkins
became the first
in his country to receive the vaccine it
was a bit nerve-wracking to start but
it's got to be done we want our
residents to see you know their loved
ones for christmas and have
if possible so it's a step in the right
direction
in northern ireland joanna sloane was
selected to become the first recipient
the pandemic forced her to postpone her
wedding
i felt pride and emotional we've worked
very hard
and to get to this point and the health
service in general
em has struggled throughout the fight
this pfizer biontech vaccine needs to be
stored at minus 70 degrees celsius
and delivered in large batches making it
difficult to send
to care home residents
but care home staff like margaret
fantastic
are a priority it's hard still that
people can't actually get to see
and hug their relatives that's a bit
heartwarming
but hopefully with something like this
and it coming in as quick and as
efficient as it has
this will help to move forward this
vaccine is one of the greatest
scientific achievements in modern
history
years of research condensed into months
almost exactly 12 months ago scientists
in china discovered a cluster of
patients
infected with a new virus nobody then
would have known about the deadly
pandemic that was to follow
here in this vial is the hope that this
pandemic
can be brought to an end
margaret celebrates her 91st birthday
next week
she and the world have been given a
priceless gift
ashish joshi sky news coventry